now sometimes news happens so fast that
we missed the obvious you know like
significant facts blow right by us such
as what happened with the reports of the
past weeks on the outgoing Obama
administration's actions toward the
incoming Trump National Security Advisor
Mike Flynn now we now know that 39 Obama
aides submitted dozens of unmasking
requests for calls that involve Flynn
the first was made by Samantha power on
November 30th 2016 with the bulk being
made between December 14th and 16th of
that year yet what everyone missed was
that there were no there was no
unmasking request made for the call that
set the criminal case against Flynn in
motion his December 28th 2016 call with
Russian ambassador Sergey kis lack the
Ingraham angle learned late last night
from a high-ranking source with direct
knowledge of that situation that it was
the FBI not the office of national
intelligence that was monitoring the
call the Washington Post confirmed this
today it was the FBI not the NSA that
wiretap kis leox calls and created the
summary and transcript when the FBI
circulated the report they included
Flynn's name from the beginning because
it was essential to understanding its
significance there was they were
therefore no requests we can conclude
for that unmasking of that information
okay
thus it was Jim Comey's FBI that had the
call transcript now did certain figures
within the FBI and consultation with
figures higher up in the administration
consider the transcript potentially I
don't know a second insurance policy
against the new administration or maybe
they thought it could be weaponized
if Flynn was asked about it later a few
days later and lied we're bound to found
out find out more now consternation was
building in the Obama ranks in December
2016 and into the next month remember we
know this I never thought Trump was
going to win the White House
and they were about to turn the keys
over to Trump a man who to their horror
vowed to undo almost everything Obama
had done on foreign and domestic policy
now I've seen many in the never Trump
world scoff at any suggestion that there
was anything improper in these flurry of
unmasking requests that were filed in
those final weeks of the Obama era yet I
think it's wrong to focus on the
unmasking itself which is legal for
years the deep state lackeys like
clapper and Brennan claimed Flynn's call
was scooped up incidentally as if it
happened almost just by accident what
exactly is going on with this engagement
with our primary adversary the Russian
that's I think why the warning lights on
everyone's dashboard with what was on it
wasn't a specific concern about my now
interesting excuse boys but we know that
you're full of it even before we heard
from that high-level source last night
recently declassified documents showed
Obama aides made 0 on masking requests
they made the day of Flynn's call with
kiss lyac so they didn't move to unmask
that call huh now on the contrary Flynn
we see it wasn't wasn't just swept up
was an incidental Flynn was targeted and
specifically he was targeted by Jim
Comey's FBI again Flynn had every right
to talk to the Russian ambassador he had
every right to discuss any aspect of
policy and any suggestion that the Logan
Act was somehow a legitimate concern of
the Obama people is just preposterous
Flynn wasn't freelancing for some
private entity against American
interests he was representing the new
administration for goodness sakes now
recently released documents show that on
January 4th 2017 the DOJ moved to close
its investigation of Flynn after it
found no derogatory information with
respect to his Russian contacts
yet mr. insurance policy himself FBI
agent Peter struck intervened to request
that this investigation remain active
and he interjected that it was the
seventh floor that was involved now the
seventh floor that's a euphemism for
senior leadership aka Jim Comey the
newly declassified memo written by Susan
Rice to herself who does that on
inauguration day 2017
now that purports to document a January
5th 2017 White House briefing that took
place for President Obama with director
call me the deputy AG Sally Yates Vice
President Biden and Susan Rice now the
memo itself is a classic Washington
mop-up operation hence Susan Swiffer
rice nickname President Obama wanted
every aspect of the investigation
handled by intelligence agencies and law
enforcement handled by the book he
stressed he wasn't asking for anything
to be initiated from a law enforcement
perspective and then reiterated again
that everything be done by the book then
again and this memo Comey was asked by
the president if the NSC should withhold
from Flynn sensitive information related
to Russia the FBI director replied
potentially even though he had no
indication thus far that Flynn had
passed classified info to kiss Lee Act
although he did note that the level of
communication was unusual there's only
one way he would know that right
spying now in her memo rice wrote that
director Comey affirmed that he was
proceeding by the book as it relates to
law enforcement now the freeze by the
book was used three times in that memo
one memo he's three times
seems like Susan Rice was swiffering up
yet another Obama mess now the phrase he
that doth protest too much
to mind now sure they were all
proceeding by the book
if proceeding by the book means
potentially withholding sensitive
information related to national security
to the incoming National Security
Adviser without any justification
whatsoever now the bottom line call me
and struck didn't like and that entrust
Flynn who Obama had fired years earlier
and they felt the same about the man who
was about to be sworn in as president
they reviled Trump this entire episode
should be both terrifying and enraging
for all Americans who think the FBI
should operate to keep us safe without
political bias oh and one more little
thing here look closely at the
Declassified memo the time stamp is
12:15 30 to 15 minutes and 32 seconds
after Susan Rice is no longer national
security adviser and 15 minutes and 32
seconds into the trump presidency this
is all weird right it's all reminiscent
of another rescue mission that she took
it upon herself to complete after
Benghazi in 2012 Susan Rice was directed
to go on national television and blame a
video for the attack on our compound
that resulted in the death of our
ambassador and three others she did her
duty repeating it and implausible and
what turned out to be false narrative
there was a violent protest outside of
our embassy sparked by this hateful
video a spontaneous reaction to what had
just transpired hours before in Cairo
which were prompted of course by the
video spontaneous reaction to what had
just transpired in Cairo as a
consequence of the video it was a terror
attack that took place a couple of
months before the presidential election
in 2012 not even a couple of months but
let's get back to the Flint affair now
what happened between January 5th and
inauguration day that spoke Susan Rice
into typing that memo into government
computers a memo about a meeting that
had taken
more than two weeks earlier now today
she claimed through a spokesperson of
course that the White House Counsel Neil
Eggleston had instructed her to do this
why is there another document that we
haven't seen yet directing struck to
keep the Flint operation going well time
will tell
or maybe John Durham well and that's the
angle